Later in this lesson,
we will discuss health information exchange for HIE,
technologies for sharing health data.
First, any transport mechanism for HIE must assure privacy, security, and trust.
Privacy means sharing data only with patient permission.
Security means protecting that data from access by unauthorized entities.
To create trust an entity must ensure
the identity of other entities with which they share data.
Here in the US, the Health Insurance Portability and Accountability Act of 1996,
or HIPA, created a privacy rule.
The government says it quote,
establishes national standards to protect
individuals' medical records and other personal health information,
and applies to health plans,
health care clearing houses,
and those health care providers that conduct
certain health care transactions electronically.
The inclusion of health insurance plans and claims clearing houses,
and the focus on electronic transactions such as claims for payment,
may seem surprising to those of us focused on clinical use cases.
But the law also mandates uniform standards for electronic transmission
of administrative and financial data relating to patient health information.
The intent was to move these transactions from paper to
electronic form and that has been quite successful.
The rule also gives patients rights over their health information,
including rights to examine and obtain a copy of their health records,
and to request corrections.
HIPA penalties can be substantial and may include prison time.
So staying within the law is a priority in virtually all healthcare organizations.